bonjour bienvenue sur lcp public sénat
c'est l'heure de parlement hebdo 45
minutes pour refaire l'aktu politique et
parlementaire de la semaine avec nick
est là naissent aujourd'hui est un bon
jour nickel la réforme constitutionnelle
mal engagée deux textes différents ont
été votées dans les deux chambres
notamment sur l'article 2 relatif à la
déchéance de nationalité
les sénateurs à majorité de droite ont
refusé de créer des apatrides pour ne
pas faire de discrimination
les jeunes les syndicats qui
maintiennent la mobilisation et la
pression contre la réforme du travail
nouvelle journée d'action que du 31 mars
le projet de loi réécrit par le
gouvernement sera présenté lui au
conseil des ministres le 24
et puis un déplacement polémique au
bataclan les députés de la commission
denquête situé après les attentats du 13
novembre se sont rendus sur les lieux
pour tenter de comprendre la chronologie
de la tacc visite choquant book
certaines familles de victimes d'autres
invités cette semaine pour commenter
toute cette actualité chantal jouanno
bonjour sénatrice udi de paris
présidente de la délégation aux droits
des femmes au sénat vice-présidente de
la région ile de france
vous allez donc pouvoir commenter
l'ensemble de cette actualité évidemment
on va commencer par le lundi avec le
gouvernement qui réécrit la future loi
de la discorde qui réforme le travail
manuel valls a donc présenté un texte
profondément remanié pour tenter
d'apaiser la contestation
la nouvelle version de la future loi
elle conneries vise à concilier
protection des salariés et souplesse
pour les entreprises elle sera à
l'épreuve des syndicats et du parlement
et les membres détails avec germain
andrieu c'est l'une des mesures clés de
la réforme du droit du travail
les barèmes truc de mots n'auront qu'une
valeur indicative c'est une victoire
pour la cfdt ferment aujourd'hui si ces
annonces se manifeste dans l'écriture du
projet de loi
la cfdt est le considère que nous avons
fait avancer ce texte est finalement
c'est bien le rôle des syndicalistes
autre modification clé attendu les
licenciements économiques
désormais le juge pourra vérifier les
critères de mauvaise santé d'une
multinationale qui souhaitent licencier
sur le territoire français c'est une
déception côté patronal qui appelle à
une vraie réforme du droit du travail
maintenant il faut continuer de parler
de discuter d'une deux surtout deux de
ne plus dénaturer cette loi parmi les
nouveaux droits non c'est la garantie
jeunes pour accompagner les décrocheurs
vers l'emploi devrait être appliquée à
tous les jeunes sans emploi aux
formations et le plafond du cps le
compte personnel de formation sera
relevé de 150 à 400 heures pour les
salariés sans diplôme pour autant la cgt
et l'unef le syndicat étudiant continue
d'appeler à la mobilisation
certains comme force ouvrière vont plus
loin et refuse cette nouvelle version
nous considérons que c'est une rupture
par rapport à la manière dont nous
négocions j'ai rappelé ce qui se passait
également dans d'autres pays donc j'ai
confirmé pour force ouvrière la demande
de suspension et comme il veut pas
suspendre de retrait du tagi le nouveau
texte sur la halle au travail sera
présenté en conseil des ministres le 24
mars chantal jouanno ya eu donc beaucoup
de modifications sur beaucoup de points
clés de ce texte est ce que pour vous la
version présentée est capable
d'encourager les embauches en cdi
puisque c'est l'un des buts de cette loi
ou non mais alors je
si on va ensuite sur le détail par
exemple sur les indemnités prud'homale
je comprends qu'il ya eu débat parce que
je trouvais que la mesure était
peut-être assez assez délicate sur le
reste important non mais c'est une
correction effectivement très importante
sur le reste sur la question du contrat
de travail
on s'oriente pas du tout vers ce qu'il
faudrait faire à savoir un contrat de
travail unique avec une acquisition
progressive de droit comme l'ont fait
les italiens
enfin pourquoi est-ce qu'on s'inspire
pas de ce qui marche ailleurs et de ce
qui crée des emplois ailleurs et
pourquoi parce qu'alors un règlement ça
se passe dans la rue parce qu'on
voudrait fait d'accord mais alors
aujourd'hui peut-être que ça coince dans
la rue mais là où ça coince réellement
c'est quand même sur le taux de chômage
espèrent qu'on nous explique qu'il faut
plus de 2 points de croissance pour
pouvoir à peine stabiliser le chômage à
un niveau vie comme extrêmement élevé
qu'on n'a pas et qu'on n'aura pas dans
les mois prochains
donc est-ce qu'on se le dise les sens
dans les selles mieux oui 1,6 pour cent
formidable merveilleux est-ce qu on se
satisfait de cette situation et ce qu'on
essaye de trouver des solutions en les
expliquant en les portant à ce problème
c'est que la gauche se met à dont la
gauche ceux qui les ont élus donc
effectivement ils ont un problème
politique mais est ce qu'on va vers la
déconnexion entre la protection sociale
et le contrat de travail c'est ce que
nous souhaitons parce que effectivement
aujourd'hui les carrières sont
chaotiques
est-ce qu'on va vers une vraie révision
du baril taris mais c'est ça que
craignent les syndicats mais à la limite
aujourd'hui à quoi est-ce qu'ils ont
mené à part effectivement à avoir d'un
côté des personnes qui ont des droits et
de l'autre côté
80 % des embauches en cdd 60% des jeunes
qui sont en cdd c'est pas ça l'avenir de
la jeu donc ça veut dire que pour vous
le gouvernement n'a pas voulu prendre le
risque d'avoir un blocage total d'une
abbaye la cedh est incertaine
oui mais de fait je crains que comme
d'habitude on part avec des grandes
ambitions on revient sur la loi et on
fait l'inversé de ce qu'on a dit au
départ c'est ça qui est allé je suis à
chaque fois qu'on veut ce gouvernement
nous parle de loi macron de choc de
simplification on arrive avec un texte
encore plus compliquée que ce qui
existait avant c'est un peu la même
chose sur cette loi travail et donc ça
ne sert pas à grand chose
voilà je crains fr très honnêtement on
n'a pas vu le texte final on avait un
avant projet d'avant projet de texte de
loi qui a été re corriger donc on se
prononce aujourd'hui sur ce qu'on
découvre au fur et à mesure quand même
qui vous satisfait ou pas notamment
peut-être la formation pour la nation la
formation c'est très bien
et on avait déjà discuté d'une loi
formation de 13 d'ailleurs j'ai pas si
vous vous en souvenez mais ça c'est très
bien et on nous on va pas critiquer la
question de la formation
mais si c'est dans un objectif de
réduire la précarité du travail et de
permettre réellement d'avoir des
embauches
je crains qu'on ne soit pas sur le bon
sujet alors vous imaginez bien que ça
fait réagir et notamment mardi eq les
réactions politiques
alors évidemment les agrégats qu'elles
n'ont pas manqué notamment à droite mais
aussi à gauche regardez le reportage
d'elisa bartholomé des concessions pour
certains un recul pour d'autres
évidemment chacun pourra ici ou là
trouver une insuffisance ou au contraire
un détail qui ne lui convient pas mais
globalement c'est un bon compromis
pourtant si la majorité des socialistes
a le sentiment d'avoir été entendu
d'autres continuent de réclamer le
retrait du texte moi je ne peux pas
considérer que beaucoup de choses ont
changé sur le licenciement en
particulier il reste facilité par ce
projet de loi ce qui est quand même le
le point dur de ce texte initialement la
droite et le centre s'était montré
plutôt favorable au projet de loi elle
conneries depuis que des modifications
ayant été apportées
l'opposition reprend son rôle pas
question de voter un tel texte qui en
termes de méthode c'est un naufrage
absolue une fois de plus ce sera le
rendez vous manqué du quinquennat
l'échec total de françois hollande c'est
inenvisageable de voter un texte comme
ça qu'ils une véritable loi contre les
pme les députés de tous bords combien
amendé le texte lors des discussions
parlementaires
mais le président du groupe socialiste
l'a assuré il y aura bien une majorité
pour voter le texte à l'assemblée
nationale
donc si on comprend bien vous vous ne
voterez pas ce texte quand il arrivera
ici au sénat attendons de voir comment
dans quel état ils arrivent à nous on
est on était très ouvert aux textes au
départ on était très ouvert à la
discussion on l'avait dit on haider ça
nous est arrivé plusieurs fois de l'otan
à droite et la sodomie pour ne pas que
le coup non mais le coup de la loi
le le pourquoi on se referme si c'est
plus du tout le texte d'origine
on n'est plus du tout dans le même
ce prix et puis on le fait effectivement
sans qu'il y ait de vraies concertation
non plus avec nous donc oui on se
referme pas ce qu'on va encore passer
beaucoup de temps à discuter d'un texte
de loi qui malheureusement va contribuer
encore à rigidifier des situations vous
pourriez peut-être tendre la main ce
gouvernement sur la question de vous
rappeler jean pierre raffarin ce qu'on
l'a déjà fait à les attentats du 13 mai
avez vous avez vous oublié on l'a déjà
fait on a voté les contrats d'avenir on
l'a déjà fait plusieurs fois on ajoute
la formation professionnelle donc ça
franchement on a plusieurs fois tendu la
main
ça ça vraiment on peut pas nous
reprocher ça la droite en tout cas la
province les républicains les
républicains en tout cas christian jacob
nous parle d'une loi anti pme
est-ce qu'il a raison il cite à la
question spécifique des indemnités
prud'homale comme je voulais dire avec
nous on est plutôt du côté des petits on
est plutôt du côté des pme dans notre
parti mais les indemnités prud'homale
s'imposer quand même pas vous pensé qu'
il peut y avoir un passage en force du
gouvernement sur ce texte à l'assemblée
avec l'usagé 49 3 points que la crise et
sont assez coutumier du fait donc entre
l'urgence à 49,3 sont pour l'urgence
visiblement oui ils sont tenaces et ils
sont assez coutumier du fait
simplement c'est plutôt un problème au
sein de leur propre majorité
en réalité aujourd'hui emmanuel macron
lui dit il faire autant en tout cas
c'est ce qu'on a lu dans un journal le
monde que finalement ils arrêtent bien
aimé que ça aille beaucoup plus loin
ça serait dommage par exemple que dans
le débat à l'assemblée ou au sénat il
n'y ait pas des choses qui puissent
revenir un petit peu sur le devant de la
scène
vous pourriez m'aider là je pense que
c'est un climat qu'on va peut-être lui
offrir une carte d'adhérent eu dès
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron la plupart
du temps ils portent des propositions
qui sont les nôtres donc c'est assez
étonnant d'ailleurs comme positionnement
politique
paris ce bien sûr qu'on va faire des
propositions bien sûr vous allez voir ça
va commencer à l'assemblée nationale
nous annoncer des choses une autre loi
était en discussion à l'assemblée après
un débat intense les députés ont voté
l'interdiction des néonicotinoïdes dans
valeur et de loi qui veut
favoriser la biodiversité alors les
néonicotinoïdes ce sont ces insectes qui
sont jugés très nocif pour les abeilles
la loi et l'interdiction s'appliquera le
1er septembre 2018 puisqu'un amendement
ps a été déposé au projet de loi sur la
biodiversité
il ya eu quand même des positions un peu
différente l'assemblée souhaitait
interdire ces pesticides mais le
ministre de l'agriculture a écrit aux
députés pour leur demander de ne pas le
faire stéphane le foll
at il été sous la pression des lobbys
pour vous écouter on a eu ce débat au
sénat puisque l'amendement goyette et
voté l'amendement dit chanteuse c'est
l'abandon qui avait déposé au sénat donc
oui c'est exactement le même texte est
déjà au sénat la gauche effectivement
avait fait adopter ce texte pour que
tout revienne au ministre de
l'agriculture donc manifestement
effectivement monsieur le foll est très
sensible au discours de certains plus
que l'autre bon on a un problème de fond
c'est la question des pollinisateurs en
général c'est pas que les abeilles c'est
tout les pollinisateurs qui contribuent
notamment par exemple à l'agriculture
maraîchère parce qu'on marque des
agriculteurs mais il ya plusieurs formes
d'agriculture qui contribuent au
développement de la faune sauvage
aujourd'hui c'est clair et la vie de
l'ansès de février le nom de clairement
c'est la guerre que certaines formes
voilà c'est une agence sanitaire
environnementale certaine forme de
néonicotinoïdes aujourd'hui sont
clairement suspecté dans la disparition
massive des abeilles qu'on observe l'air
c'est une des éclairs c'est dans la vie
oui c'est dans la vie c'est la raison
pour laquelle on avait porté
effectivement cette cet amendement donc
soit on prend des mesures on a dit 2018
ce qui laisse le temps de trouver des
produits de substitution
si vraiment on coince d'ici 2018 je fais
que tout à fait confiance au ministère
de l'agriculture pour dire c'est pas
possible il faut qu'on risque d'avoir
des alternatives pire donc il faut
peut-être qu'on trouve des de temps en
temps des exceptions près ce qu'il faut
de mérule dans ce domaine on peut pas
remettre une autre substance en reprise
enfin je sais pas si vous allez regarder
les derniers chiffres d'utilisation des
pesticides en france qui montre une
véritable explosion de l'utilisation non
seulement mais que vous avez dans les
magasins si vous trouvez tous ses
produits dans l'air
vous oui on les retrouve non mais
au-delà de ça dans le mot qu'une très
rarement à ce que dit le ministre et
contrairement à ce qu'on avait engagé
sur le plan de réduction de déficit
sanitaires on prend la voie inverse donc
ce gouvernement dit des choses il fait
l'envers ce il fait l'inversé là avec
les nouveaux de nicotine ride on le voit
il fait exactement voyez un double
discours de stéphane le foll ah bah oui
je voulais c'est évident qu'un double
discours il dit des choses regarder les
chiffres sur les pesticides effrayant
quand même attendre et cécilia side site
ça veut dire pour tuer sont aussi vaut
aussi pour nous mêmes pour le pour
l'être humain
ben on a en effet de chaîne évidemment
quand vous avez une disparition massive
d'abeilles on a eu le cas dans d'autres
pays il faut les remplacer il faut
remplacer les pollinisateurs basse et
vous n'avez pas de fruit sans
pollinisateurs vous n'avez pas de donc
c'est une évidence et c'est nocif pour
la santé c'est nocif pour l'économie va
passer au mercredi on va commencer avec
cette loi qui est arrivé au sénat sur la
réforme de la constitution c'était
mercredi est au coeur de cette loi on
retrouve le très controversé texte sur
la déchéance de nationalité le sénat à
majorité de droite soit réécrire
complètement ce texte le premier
ministre lui a pris à témoin les
sénateurs regardez cette première
journée d'examen de cette réforme de la
constitution avec mounir souci
manuel valls arrive au sénat pour
constater un profond désaccord dans les
premières minutes de son discours le
premier ministre a dénoncé l'attitude de
la majorité sénatoriale
la droite a modifié le texte adopté par
les députés notamment sur la question de
la déchéance de nationalité
ce consensus nous l'avons construit à
l'assemblée nationale gouvernement
majorité mais aussi une très large part
de l'opposition
je regrette profondément à ce stade bien
sûr que cette construction collective ne
puisse pas être conforté
au sénat les députés ont étendu la
déchéance de nationalité à tous les
citoyens français
en commission les sénateurs on te
souhaiter revenir à une mesure qui ne
s'appliquerait qu'aux binationaux qui
aurait pu prévoir
jour un premier ministre se prétendant
de gauche seraient d'accord pour créer
des apatrides
alors que toute la tradition
républicaine c'est quand même de ne pas
multiplier les cas d'apatridie le débat
s'enlise sur cette question et de
nombreux parlementaires souhaitent qu'il
s'achève au plus vite plus pas pour que
les navettes continue de façon indéfinie
si le sénat aujourd'hui refusent ce
compromis de l'assemblée nationale
je pense qu'il faut que ses
responsabilités et dire stop là cette
décision signoret l'abandon de la
réforme constitutionnelle
après quatre mois de débats extrêmement
sensible est ce que vous voulez le
congrès à versailles au pavot on va
revenir sur le fond d'abord la droite 1
même si je suis pas d'accord avec eux au
sénat ils ont raison de dire que c'est
le gouvernement qui a changé de textes
puisque ce que le premier le président
de la république nous on les a joués ce
qu'on première promo pro majorité que le
président avait annoncé au congrès
c'était quand même effectivement une
déchéance réservé à ceux qui ont une
autre nationalité donc ils ont changé le
texte anglais uniquement parce que leur
propre majorité n'était pas n'étaient
pas d'accord donc ça c'est vrai
deuxièmement c'est pas que la droite
et comme une bonne partie de la gauche
qui elle aussi est contre ce et ce texte
donc c'est que ce sont des clivages qui
divise au sein même des partis puisque
c'est là que vous vous voulez quoi
moi je suis pas d'accord avec la
position qui a été celle de mon groupe
au sénat moi je suis pour le fait que
cette déchéance de nationalité un
effectivement soit possible 2 soit
inscrit dans la constitution et 3 soit
pour tous les français qui prennent les
armes contre leur pays c'est pas la
france qu'ils créent les apatrides c'est
ceux qui prennent les armes contre leur
pays qui choisissent cette situation ne
faut pas inverser non plus à des
terroristes et là on parle de
terroristes on parle de personnes qui
ont pris les armes contre leur pays et
on parle de décision qui de toute façon
vous quand même passé par différents
prix ce qui fait que ça va pas concerner
énormément de monde et donc c'est
vraiment des personnes qui ont fait ce
choix
moi je souhaiterais que le texte puisse
aller au bout évidemment je souhaite pas
parce que ça me semble légitime ou ceux
qui me disent ça sert à rien je suis
d'accord il faudrait avoir les vrais
débats les démineurs ont formé un peu
sur le fond parce que c'est par là il ya
la dimension politique mais là le fond
il faudra qu'on est vrai débat sur les
moyens ça je suis d'accord mais dire que
ça sert à rien ça veut dire que la
nationalité ça sert à rien c'est pas du
tout ma vision de la république pourquoi
il n'y a pas de
compromis au sénat parce que c'est
vraiment et c'est vraiment un débat je
vous dit il traverse les partis
politiques entre ceux qui disent on veut
pas d'être patrick et ceux qui disent on
veut pas considérer qu'un français de
souche qui prend les armes contre son
pays saurait plus fins de mois menace
émise divisions profondes une divination
division très profonde et très politique
et très sensée conviction et démarre
enfin mal et oui même dans les débats
ont été de très bon niveau je veux dire
que la la la discussion générale sur
c'était un très bon débat c'est un débat
de fond
ce n'est pas une opposition de principe
c'est vraiment des convictions
différentes qui s'amusaient dans le
décompte des différentes qu'ils
s'opposeraient entendu le premier dans
ce reportage en gros il vous dit de
toute façon votre texte il passera pas
l'assemblée nationale ce que vous faites
ça arrive c'est le discours de le
discours du premier ministre surtout sa
réponse d'ailleurs à l'issue de la
discussion générale a été
particulièrement appréciée hier c'était
autant le débat a été un vrai débat de
fond longtemps sa réponse a été très
agressive aussi bien vis-à-vis de la
droite d'ailleurs que vis-à-vis des
communismes une désocialisation même de
la partie des socialistes qui ne voulait
pas du texte c'est pas son rôle de
premier ministre
là on parle pas d'un petit texte de loi
on parle de la révision de la
constitution c'est pas son rôle de
premier ministre
moi j'attends passage d'un premier don
qui l'attendent aller d'aller vite de
vouloir éviter de vouloir presser les
jardins de la révision de la
constitution ne devrait la salle quand
bush à sa sécession
on révise la constitution avec une
immense prudence c'est un texte
fondateur et avec des papas autant de
divisions donc avec autant de divisions
comment envisager le congrès à la
jeunesse sur l'article 2 en l'occurrence
donc celui qui concerne la déchéance de
nationalité je ne vois pas comment il
aura une majorité au congrès vous les
voyez pas aujourd'hui et maintenant on
ne va pas regarder ce qui s'est passé au
jour 2 de cette réforme
constitutionnelle c'était jeudi
donc la déchéance de nationalité a été
votée dans l'hémicycle tout compromis
est-il encore possible ou pas n'ont
visiblement selon chantal jouanno on
regarde le reportage de manière sexy
comme prévu le débat sur la déchéance de
nationalité a confirmé le fossé entre
les deux chambres
les députés souhaité que cette sanction
s'applique à tous les auteurs de crimes
terroristes
les sénateurs sont revenus à une version
où seuls les binationaux sont concernés
cette modification met en péril toute la
réforme constitutionnelle avant
d'envisager n'importe quelle hypothèse
moi j'espère encore convaincre le sénat
de bâtir un compromis avec l'assemblée
nationale nous en sommes loin
c'est ce que j'ai voulu dire hier durant
toute la discussion le premier ministre
a appelé le sénat à faire preuve de
responsabilité en se ralliant au
consensus trouvé à l'assemblée cet
argument n'a eu aucun effet les
sénateurs justifient leur position de
refus par la défense d'un principe et
chacun nous une responsabilité sur les
libertés
une responsabilité sur la nécessaire
sécurité des français sur la force des
symboles et par lui ces symboles ya
aussi l'apatridie qui est quand même qui
est quand même une valeur que je croyais
imaginer ne pas être abandonnée par la
gauche ces difficultés rendre la tenue
du congrès incertaine
manuel valls met en garde l'opposition
de droite en annonçant que le parlement
serait ridiculiser si le débat
s'éternise et chantal jouanno vous
disiez juste à voir ce reportage que
vous sembler difficile de trouver une
majorité au congrès si jamais on disait
par exemple on arrête l'article 2 de
l'article de sa déchéance on passe à
autre chose on garde que l'article
munster sur l'état d'urgence et pourquoi
pas ce qu'on appelle la réforme du
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
est ce que c'est quelque chose que vous
pourriez signé et voter sur l'état
d'urgence
oui évidemment la même demandé le
conseil d'état d'ailleurs dans son avis
la recommander pour encadrer cet état
d'urgence qu'il est très peu aujourd'hui
pour éviter par exemple la dissolution
du parlement pendant l'état d'urgence
sont que ça on le demande on le souhaite
vraiment la réforme du conseil supérieur
de la magistrature que nous portons que
notre pays berti pardon a toujours porté
enfin c'est vraiment
autre débat on a le motionnaire on peut
dire fourre-tout du coup on en profite
pour passer à autre chose
c'est en terme de respect du temps
politique je trouve pas ça terrible tu
es donc l'article
ah oui tout mélanger avec la réforme du
csm même si nous souhaitons cette
réforme
ça nous semble être vraiment un autre
débat politique avec les socialistes ont
besoin de vos voix parce qu'il faut les
3/5 pour pouvoir réunir ce concret donc
ils vont aller chercher les centristes
oui mais la moisson fut long mais c'est
la question c'est pas de savoir comment
on fait de la comptabilité
c'est aussi on a des principes de fond
qu'on partage on n'était pas au meilleur
partage qui se partagent l'état
d'urgence on partage cette nécessaire
inscriptions de l'état d'urgence et
cette nécessaire création de bornes à
l'état d'urgence
on partage demain s'ils le font demain
la réforme du csm n'est pas une
discussion de fond
oui mais qu'avec discussions font aimer
comment vous faites concrètement il ya
effectivement certains sénateurs qui ont
proposé de ne voter que cet article 1
mais ça fait partie d'un même texte du
jazz elles sont deux sujets très
différents mais ils font partie d'un
même thème
aujourd'hui le 89 de la constitution dit
qu'on ne peut pas détacher les articles
vont voter sur l'ensemble un an mais
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui la question de
l'état d'urgence est une question
différente de celle de la déchéance de
nationalité alors on la mettra dans un
an on proposerait un autre thème à la
déchéance de nationalité si j'ai bien
compris et autant pour des raisons de
divisions internes à la gauche
d'ailleurs que aujourd'hui je vois
difficilement comment on trouve un
consensus sur ce un sujet aussi lourd on
est dans une impasse où je me rendais
dans une impasse alors passons un sujet
social s'est elle annonce forte de la
semaine puisque le gouvernement a fait
un geste pour les 5 millions 600 mille
fonctionnaires le point d'indicé de la
fonction publique est relevé de 1 2% une
première depuis six ans germain andrieu
la négociation était très attendu après
six ans de gel le gouvernement a décidé
de relever le point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires
aujourd'hui la réponse du gouvernement
c'est 1,2 pour cent d'augmentation sur 2
ans 0 6% au 1er juillet 2016 et 0 6% au
1er février 2010 est un 10 2 % contre 1
% proposée initialement c'est 2,4
milliards d'euros pour le budget de la
france dont près de 550 millions pour
les hôpitaux et 648 millions d'euros
pour la fonction publique territoriale
le geste est bien significatif qu'il
n'est pas symbolique et qu'il va
permettre aux agents de voir leurs
feuilles de paye progresser et pour nous
c'était notre première revendication le
dégel du point d indice
pourtant la majorité des syndicats
jugent eux geste insuffisant à un an de
l'élection présidentielle
la cgt est le premier syndicat dans la
fonction publique veut aller plus loin
nous véritablement ce que nous croyons
c'est qu'il faut de nouveau pesé par le
rapport de force
encore une fois obtenir plus je rappelle
par ailleurs que le gouvernement est en
place au moins jusqu'en mai 2017 et donc
il ya encore du temps il ya encore des
moyens pour nous pour faire plus que
d'autres gouvernements n'a proposé
aujourd'hui prochaine étape la
consultation des instances syndicales et
des adhérents en vue d'une éventuelle
mobilisation le 22 mars question ça
parce qu'il le mérite
les fonctionnaires cette revalorisation
du point d'indicé est l'élément
fonctionnaires beaucoup de choses
honnêtement il travaille il travaille
quand même très bien on a la chance
d'avoir une administration d'état des
collectivités territoriales et
hospitalières
ça c'est pas là le problème de savoir
s'il le mérite ou pas les salariés du
privé aussi le mérite c'est pas ça le
sujet le sujet c'est ce que notre
situation économique le permet à votre
situation économique ne le permet pas
très clairement on a un problème
d'endettement chronique de l'état ça va
coûter 2,4 milliards d'euros
non seulement à l'état mais aux
collectivités territoriales ce qui fait
que les collectivités vont moins
investir ce qui fait que c'est moins de
croissance pour demain
donc on a un problème est qu'on ne peut
pas se permettre d'en qu'on a
aujourd'hui dans comptes à l'état actuel
d'un smic dépend depuis 2008
depuis 2008 de début de la crise
on est quand même dans une situation de
stagflation
voilà un peu de pas de croissance
validation pas de croissance pas
d'inflation
on est dans une situation d'endettement
chronique la baisse des dotations ne
serait ce que pour la région ile de
france c'est 140 millions d'euros 140
millions d'euros c'est autant en moins
d'investissement et de croissance pour
demain donc réfléchissons à al'inverse
l'augmentation du temps de travail dans
la fonction publique comme dans le privé
réfléchissons à linverse à des des
systèmes nous on allait lui des systèmes
ou au compte effectivement vous pouvez
avoir des systèmes d'eau supplémentaires
vous pouvez avoir des système de
gratification mais là en l'occurrence
alors pardon mais personne n'est dupe 1
on est à un an et demi des
présidentielles dont on achète la
fonction publique et on achète et
syndicats parce qu'en plus il faut faire
passer la loi de malouas de madame l
conneries la ficelle est un peu grosse
un peu grosse électoraliste mais pas
seulement
si ben franchement électoralistes non
c'est ce que la situation économique est
merveilleuse est-ce que ce qui
justifiait de 2010 aux entreprises
augmenter les prix oui et alors comment
ça se passe dans le privé aujourd'hui
comment ça se passe ce que la situation
économique le permet malheureusement non
ça va moi j'ai un vrai sujet d'équité
même par rapport à cette a7 à cette
mesure va pas opposer le privé public
c'est pas le sujet mais on a un problème
de situation économique aujourd'hui un
pays donné dans le marasme et quand on
se satisfait de 1,6 pour cent de
croissance potentielle avec le taux de
chômage qu'on a mais franchement c'est
une blague
donc si je vous entends bien on va
aggraver les déficits on fait de
l'électoralisme
c'est une erreur une faute politique
qu'on est en train de commettre pour les
années futures annonces et une stratégie
politique c'est une faute pour la france
mais il ya une autre mesure qui a été
annoncée par michel sapin l'a promis
l'imposition à la source pour tout le
monde dès 2018
est ce que cette fois il a raison
d'avancer sur un sujet aussi oui alors
mérilheu un an de lancer après c'est
effectivement le problème c'est que
c'était un engagement de campagne et
qu'on est à un an de la présidence que
ça va pas être
demandez ce que vous savez que tout
problème en fait c'est cette année
blanche ce temps les dents les
impositions oui c'est une bonne chose
imposition se fait dans d'autres pays ça
simplifie la vie des gens donc c'est
plutôt une bonne chose donc on est pour
maintenant effectivement il ya le
problème des blancs de faire et comment
est-ce qu'on va gérer cette fameuse
cette fameuse année blanche alors une
vingtaine de députés étaient cette
semaine sur les lieux du bataclan où a
eu lieu l'attaqué la plus meurtrière du
13 novembre
leur objectif comprendre les
circonstances de cette attaque et les
conditions d'intervention des forces de
l'ordre visite controversée
jean baptiste daoulas le rideau du
bataclan s'est ouvert à nouveau pour une
vingtaine de députés est venue faire la
lumière sur la soirée du 13 novembre
après deux mois d'audition la commission
d' enquête sur les attentats de l'année
2015 à des questions très précises
pourquoi at il fallu trois heures entre
la première attaque
hélas hélas au final pourquoi at il
fallu aussi trois heures pour que les
secours puissent extraire les victimes
qui étaient encore présentes dans le
bataclan ces questions-là auxquelles
nous devons répondre c'est le but de
notre déplacement mais la réouverture du
bataclan pour les députés et la présence
du raid de la police et de la br i pour
répondre à leurs questions à choquer
quelques familles de victimes
des parents qui n'étaient pas conviés
aujourd'hui et se plaignent d'être tenus
à l'écart de l'anc est depuis novembre
pourquoi ont-ils besoin de venir là
regardez ce qui s'est passé mobiliser
les forces du raid et de la verrerie
alors que nos parents nous ne savons
toujours pas à quelle heure nos enfants
sont décédés à la sortie du bataclan les
députés disent comprendre la douleur des
familles des victimes
mais il justifie leur présence nous
sommes là si nous avons créé cette
commission denquête c'est sans doute
pour être à même de faire des
propositions que ces propositions permet
d'éviter ce genre de choses et bien
s'cusez moi ça se passe aussi ici et
savoir pourquoi c'est pourquoi il s'est
passé sur ce drame
essayez d'imaginer tous ensemble
d'ailleurs les des solutions pour éviter
ça se reproduise les députés vont
continuer leurs travaux à huis clos ils
sont en train d'entendre un commissaire
divisionnaire à l'assemblée nationale
chantal jouanno est ce le rôle de
parlementaire de prendre ce genre
d'initiatives habituellement réservé à
la justice les reconstitutions sont
normalement réservé effectivement aux
enquêtes judiciaires et la justice nous
notre rôle de parlementaire quand on
fait une commission denquête c'est
d'aller effectivement identifier les
dysfonctionnements de l'administration
ou du pouvoir exécutif d'ailleurs en
général pour pouvoir apporter des
corrections
là j'avoue que ça me va je vois pas en
quoi ça peut aider le travail de fond de
la commission denquête de l'assemblée
nationale je je je vois assez mal en
quoi c'est pas le rôle s'il ya des
dysfonctionnements de la police on à
l'igpn qui peut tout à fait faire ce
travail de reconstitution
donc je les ai voulu faire quoi coup de
com' c'est surtout elle qu'il faut poser
la question
non ils ne me répondent non pas parce
qu'ils sont pris ils ont pris
l'initiative
vous êtes parlementaire est ce que vous
auriez adhérer à cette commission
denquête par exemple c'est la principale
commission denquête de voir s'il y eu
des dysfonctionnements c'est plutôt une
bonne chose
allez je j'aurais été extrêmement gêné
je passe je vois pas en quoi ça aurait
aidé mon travail de réflexion d'aller
participer à une reconstitution honteux
a réagi l'avocat des familles de
victimes
partagez cet avis je pense que la
douleur des victimes et dell donc
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que c'est
rajouter quand même un peu de douleur à
la douleur
chantal jouanno ginger à c est avec nous
c'est notre partenaire du ska nîmes
avoir hébergé dans quelques petites
secondes tout d'avoir catllar va parler
un petit peu d'europe un peu d'europe
puisque il ya sommet des chefs d'état et
de gouvernement à bruxelles à nouveau
sommet avec la turquie l'europe essaie
de régler le problème des migrants elle
compte sur la turquie pour reprendre un
maximum de réfugiés en échange d'une
aide de trois milliards d'euros
chantal jouanno cette entente cet accord
en train d'être signé avec la turquie ne
plaît pas à tout le monde
en france 64 députés républicains et de
votre parti du pays se sont opposés à
toute négociation qui pourrait entraîner
une adhésion d'ankara à
l'union européenne vous dites quoi vous
par rapport à hong hong et européens
fédéralistes
on est assez rare donc il faut le
rappeler et on est opposé aujourd'hui à
tout nouvel élargissement de l'europe
circoncis et même opposé à
l'élargissement à dernier élargissement
à la croatie donc voilà c'est ça le fond
notre position on va dire que l'europe
aujourd'hui et dans un dans une telle
faiblesse politique alors qu'il faudrait
au contraire avoir des cercles
concentriques c'est une vieille idée ça
d'ailleurs un pour avoir des politiques
beaucoup plus intégrée qu'aujourd'hui
tout nouvel élargissement alors là en
plus c'est dans un bain dans un c'est
une négociation quoi c'est du
donnant-donnant fait du chantage
vous êtes fan page mais c'est du
donnant-donnant c'est quand même ça fait
longtemps que la turquie est
effectivement veut se rapprocher de
l'europe qu'on ait des partenariats
privilégiés c'est parfaitement normal
parce que c'est quand même un grand un
grand voisin mais le principe même d'un
nouvel élargissement aujourd'hui dans la
situation de l'europe ne l'est
maintenant
l'europe at-elle raison de faire
confiance aux turcs en tout cas pour
rire on recommence à résonner d'en
arriver là défiance permanente on va pas
faire grand-chose question peut se poser
au net
la question peut se poser certes mais on
est quand même son nouveau voisin on ne
peut pas faire sans eux
et sur la question des réfugiés vous
avez vu aussi ce qui est proposé par
l'union européenne à réfugiés contraints
migros un peu schématique un peu résumé
commerce a l'habitude en 13 14
comme d'habitude on traite pas la
question de fond la question de fond
c'est un militairement effectivement en
termes de sécurité
comment est-ce qu'on n'aborde la
question dans ces pays là et les erreurs
on les assume les erreurs passées
2 comment on assume du développement
dans ses dents c'est bel et bien on
ferait mieux de se préoccuper de savoir
combien on met d'argent dans le projet
d'électrification en afrique qui est
porté par gérard l'eau non mais j tiji
tient parce que si vous avez si vous
avez de la pauvreté vous avez des
tensions c'est inévitable mais c'est un
combat de longue haleine
oui c'est un combat de longue haleine
mais à force de repousser voilà dans la
quelle situation se trouve
allez on va passer à la loupe du scan
gym jara c est avec mu les frais
jim fin prêt c'est à vous bonjour
chantal jouanno est ce qu'on va parler
de la primaire de la droite ou de la
primaire de la droite et du centre
c'est la grande question qui va être
tranchées notamment ce week-end lors du
congrès de l'udps lit les militants
étaient appelés à voter jusqu'à jusqu'à
demain ça semble assez mal embarquée
pour tout dire puisque on entendait
encore ce matin jean christophe lagarde
appelé les adhérents à refuser cette
primaire ils lui réclament des gages aux
républicains sur la question de la ligne
sur la question des places aux
législatives
le bras de fer est ce que c'est la bonne
façon de procéder sur cette question on
a un partenaire parce qu'on a lu des
s'est toujours inscrite comme
effectivement partis partenaires mais
pas un parti subalternes ou soumis ça
c'est une grande différence par rapport
à la tradition passé on a un parti
partenaire qui nous dit grosso modo
venez venez parce que la menace du front
national est telle qu'on peut pas partir
divisés n'est pas on a dit banco
on leur a écrit on leur a dit on
commence à discuter délégation a
délégation avec plusieurs représentants
des républicains de leur côté et nous on
avait plusieurs représentants de le lui
dire
ces discussions n'ont jamais eu lieu ja
la photokina nicolas sarkozy la balle
est dans leur camp on était prêts on
leur a écrit les discussions n'ont
jamais la faute à qui on va pas
personnalisé c'est globalement les
républicains puisqu'ils étaient tous
faut qu on s'est fait globalement les
d'ailleurs tout d'un coup c'est assez
marrant parce que comme du coureur des
bois très bien on va poser la question
telle quelle à nos militants puisque
c'était notre engagement on a toujours
dit que maintenant cédées sont les
militants qui vont décider donc on leur
pose la question je suis en l'absence
d'accord puisqu'il n'y a pas d'accord
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on participe à la
primaire mais nos militants ils sont ils
sont attachés à lui des niveaux bas et
c'est probable c'est probable moi je
rêve avec le choix des militants ils
sont encore en train de voter mais sur
le fond vous est ce que
dans ce décor élan tout de toutes ces
questions de lignes et de place aux
législatives
est ce que vous vous êtes pour un
candidat udi dans ce système de
primaires oui ou non
alors aujourd'hui alors qu'il ya aucun
accord sur la ligne ou quimper est ce
qu'on est fédéraliste est ce qu'on est
d'accord sur le fait simplement comporte
les relations l'ourson d'avoir mais
c'est un candidat
là vous raisonnez en comptabilité
politiques comme les républicains
aujourd'hui nous on vous parle de fond
est ce que on est d'accord pour dire que
l'europe c'est une priorité ou pas moi
c'est ça mon sujet il énerve ça n'a
parlé de fond les républicains n'est pas
le patron à baho aux côtés ils n'ont pas
voulu nous répondre
jamais par le moi je ne leur dis mais
écoutez franchement venez pas nous
reprocher le fait de pas participer
alors que vous ne nous avait jamais
accepté à la table des négociations
probablement parce que moi je suis eu
des directs
nous allons à différentes composantes
quoi ça sert c'est comme à l'ump il ya
différentes têtes tête de figure moi je
suis d'eric à chaque fois que j'ai
rencontré les militants de l'udps et ils
sont 1 radicalement indépendantiste
vraiment ils sont opposés à toute forme
de soumission et à cette espèce de
chantage sur si vous venez pas on va
être divisé c'est pas bien est ce que ça
veut dire que si les adhérents refuse ce
week end
le système la première ce sera
définitivement difficile définitivement
pardon terminé qui aura pas de candidat
la question telle qu'elle est posée
c'est comme n'y a pas d'accord enfin
l'absence d'accord est ce qu'on
participe si demain tout d'un coup parce
que là tout d'un coup ils sont très
agités
tout d'un coup il y à un accord on
reposera la question militants notre
engagement c'est pas c'est pas à tête de
partis à peut-être deux parties nous on
demande à nos militants bien le club
dans la négociation c'est pas une
première étape après honnêtement on va
voir ce qu'ils proposent
parce que là haut sur la plupart des
candidats il ils sont très intéressés à
nous dire si si on discute on va
discuter après alors parlons d'emmanuel
coste c'était votre adversaire lors des
élections régionales à l'issue desquels
elle a été réélue conseil régional
adversaire coupe de france qu'on
concurrente alors entre temps on l'a vu
à les rentrer au gouvernement et
visiblement ça lag à ce qu'on puisse lui
reprocher en son cumul entre sa fonction
ministérielle et son mandat local de
conseil régional qui rappelons le ce
cumul n'est pas interdit en tout à fait
vous avez été élu dans dix ans je serai
la seule liste non cumul et vous cumulez
pas de mandat merda jeu sur les points
de qi
maintenant je joue pas sur les mots
c'est vous qui comprenait pas je
comprends très bien que vous cumulez
incroyable questions très simples
chantal jouanno est ce que emmanuelle
cosse tout comme son vincent placé par
exemple doit démissionner de son mandat
de conseil régional pour se consacrer
intégralement à ses fonctions
ministérielles
mais en fait ce qui se passe pourquoi
est-ce que vous arrêtez pas de les
titiller comme ça c'est comme quand il
était avant dans l'opposition ils
n'arrêtaient pas de nous dire mais vous
vous c'est inadmissible parce que moi
j'ai été ministre et conseillère
régionale mais j h mais jai jamais dit
je vais démissionner je vais tout à fait
assumée alors qu'est-ce que j'ai pas
pris dans les dents sur le thème c'est
inadmissible vous êtes miss vous êtes
ministre vous cumulez alors il
n'arrêtait pas là tout d'un coup c'est
comme le pauvre sage avec sa main
français avec savanna il se retrouve
dans la même situation
donc voila vous l'avait dit et le cumul
pour l'instant n'est pas interdit
effectivement ce n'est pas inintéressant
non plus pour un ministre de conserver
un pied dans la réalité la bad les deux
ministres au final
je passe certains ministres d'être en
même temps président de région
d'ailleurs donc aujourd'hui voilà cemex
est autant l'assumer ce qui se passe
pour emmanuel fois c'est quand elle a
été tellement tellement virulentes sur
ce cumul des mandats que aujourd'hui va
ça se retourne effectivement un petit
peu comme contrainte comme quoi il faut
toujours être un peu modeste dans nos
positions dans une tribune au figaro ce
matin nicolas sarkozy s'insurge contre
le choix de françois hollande de
commémorer demain 19 mars le
cessez-le-feu de la guerre d'algérie
c'est une date qui fait pas l'unanimité
pour moi parce que après cette date il
ya eu des massages encore donc au
décalage de d'art qui est aujourd'hui
des familles s'insurge contre eux contre
cette commémoration est ce que c'est une
erreur de jugement de la part de
l'elysée
je comprends très mal pourquoi françois
hollande surtout aujourd'hui fait ça je
vraiment très mal parce que le président
de la république surtout sur une date de
commémoration ça a vocation à rassembler
à créer effectivement une mémoire
collective partagée ce problème de cette
date
moi j'ai beaucoup l'occasion de
travailler dessus de la question des
harkis
ça a été atroce la suite a été atroce
avec une france la guerre a continué ces
gens se trouvaient massacrer mais
vraiment massacrés alors qu'ils
portaient le drapeau de la france dans
leur coeur et c'est pour ça avant moi
dirhams à vis à vis des harkis que j'ai
beaucoup suivi samassa me blesse moi je
suis pas requis mais j'ai beaucoup suivi
cette question là dans une vie
antérieure
et pour eux je trouve ça très douloureux
donc on fait plaisir même si je sais pas
qui ont fait plaisir c'est mais je pense
que c'est c'est mal pesé quoi enfin pour
un président de la république
aujourd'hui dans un pays qui est quand
même à a besoin de rassemblement
quelle tristesse nicolas sarkozy parle
de guerre des mémoires c'est bien c'est
35 ans après on est les plaies ne sont
toujours pas refermées on a toujours ces
débats là en france
est ce qu'on a toujours des membres dans
les familles qui ont vécu ça parce que
il ya quand même effectivement pour la
france vis-à-vis des harkis toujours une
question de bah oui oui c'est quand même
cela y va c'est qu'il est toujours là
pas réglé question dernière question
mardi soir une réunion d'information sur
l'installation d'un centre d'hébergement
pour sdf dans le 16e arrondissement a eu
lieu ça a été très très très très chaud
ça a été perturbée par certains
riverains qui n'ont pas hésité à
insulter les élus de la mairie de paris
et les représentants de la préfecture
est ce que vous dénoncez sa tête cette
attitude est ce que vous comprenez les
inquiétudes des habitants du 16e
arrondissement
il ya eu des mots qui n'ont pas leur
place dans des débats publics
franchement les débats publics sont
faits là pour effectivement réfléchir
ensemble et pas pour être aussi dur et
parfois caricaturales ensuite c'est vrai
qu'à mérite pas et jouent beaucoup la
provocation sur les photos c'est quand
j'entends anne hidalgo c'est vraiment
alors là vous allez voir dans le xvième
c'est parce que comme vous connaissez
pas la vraie vie on va vous apprendre ce
que c'est que la vraie vie moi j'ai un
sujet c'est la défense absolue de la
préservation des espaces qui sont si
rares les espaces non bâtis dans le
cloaque boulogne parce que on le
grignote jour après jour ce pauvre ce
pauvre bois de boulogne
après qu'ils aient des centres de
effectivement pour accueillir des
personnes défavorisées partout c'est
parfaitement normal donc sur le principe
d'accueillir deux personnes défavorisées
au contraire c'est parfaitement
c'est parfaitement normal mais cette
date est pour la judéité surtout pas sur
les haies qui veut dire au final c'est
tellement rare ans alors en tout cas
surtout sur paris et en ile de france
ont en général on en perd en permanence
corps au final plutôt pour mes problèmes
de méthode problèmes sont de moi j'ai
entendu est vraiment c'était on va
mettre de l'huile sur le feu parce que
plus ça va réagir mieux ce soir merci ce
sera le mot de la fin merci chantal
jouanno se retrouve la semaine prochaine
chez dumont surtout wallace motion très
bonne semaine
qui